hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
küche
ich möchte heute die kleine sommerpause
ankündigen
und zwar so wie gerade mitten in der
buchproduktion mein neues bad bekommt
nämlich dem legt momentan ist mache ich
abends immer freue mich über die küche
auf und misst diese august und gucke
immer
deswegen sind wir jetzt auch nicht im
urlaub letztes jahr waren wir auch die
zeile urlaub wie jedes jahr im august da
ist auch das thema urlaub aber dieses
jahr mal zackig wir bleiben hier
zum einen muss der garten richtig schön
geworden und zum anderen hat das buch
außerdem bereiten wir uns gerade auch
die ifo forscher sehen wir nämlich am
siebten september bei porsche um stammt
wie die letzten jahre auch da können wir
uns besuchen von morgens bis abends ich
mache da 3d koch und back zeiten also da
könnt ihr da kommen schon da werde ich
dann kochen und backen wobei das mit
dabei die nehmer den mitnehmen oder den
aber auch mit und wir arbeiten derzeit
auch an unserer als männer eigenen f
denn ihr habt ja schon ganz oft gefragt
und wir sind jetzt echt schon lange dran
und jetzt sowas geht ja nicht von heute
auf morgen das heißt die ganzen
funktionen müssen ausprobiert werden
alles was im block abgeändert werden das
schlägt sich unglaublich viel arbeit was
ich gerade im hintergrund alles passiert
wie gesagt die küche wird immer wieder
ausgemistet eingeräumt denn hier sind
auch viele die hier in der küche mit
dabei sind das heißt wenn manchmal
natürlich freund und ich richtig finde
ich mir wieder also muss man regelmäßig
aufräumen
wir arbeiten gerade deswegen schuldig
wir arbeiten gerade noch an viel
[Musik]
neu ist dann machen wir noch gereinigt
hier bin ja etwas richtig cool
ja und zwar die app die wird so was wie
ein rezept immer haben und zwar was ist
links und rechts schieben
oh ja du kannst das wieder auch direkt
mit der app im shop einkaufen ist
möglich dann kann's halt auch von
zehntausenden als favorit speicher haben
dann kannst du es in den einkaufskorb
legen kann es schon was habe ich schon
das brauche ich noch an zutaten also
richtig und was auch wurdest du kannst
zum beispiel wenn ihr ein home connect
fähiges gerät habe dann könnt ihr zum
beispiel haben rezepten kuchen wunder
serie schickt ihn an den backofen der
banken stellt sich automatisch an die
temperatur die zeit brauchen theoretisch
kein buch mehr stimmt wahrscheinlich
backzeit temperatur und sie hat genau
und die sting hat der männer genau
wissen hat sich entwickelt
das wird spaßig und richtig lustig freut
euch die stadt die ifa mit mega wo ihr
euch fragen wir schauen wir noch ein
quatsch und rezepte für ideen habt oder
wünsche hat was ich euch kochen soll
oder hatten soll schreibt gerne
der mann musste sein und es gibt bully
weg über eine umfrage über 500 nur die
bergs gibt so wie letztes jahr auch
packen wir kommen zum samstag noch die
ifa-besucher wir werden vielleicht um
videos über machen bevor noch
wahrscheinlich versucht gerade ein paar
akten abzuzocken freikarten für euch
also habt schon meinen kopf und dann
habe ich noch einige genug okay das war
doch auch ihn mit cooler fieber mehr
kulisse anzeigen wir werden vielleicht
so ein button haben wo man auf den knopf
drücken und an diesem tag wird die app
online gehen ob wir das schaffen weist
diese optimiert sind ja wie sollen wir
drücken auf den button braucht und dann
knallt richtig die im fernsehen
fernsehen genau und damit
das wird am samstag den linken seite
sind erneut geht die online richtige
sting und die app wird auch
höchstwahrscheinlich kostenlos sein
wer bis kostenlos erreichten einen
türkischen war was die abendsonne trifft
die man sich schon jetzt trifft dich
erwischen abschauen wie mir schien ok
schön ja ansonsten wie gesagt immer ein
backbuch klang im ganzen rhein main
teilchen falls ja warum eigentlich weil
das ist die photosynthese unter wasser
und ich muss ja jetzt und was rein geben
das ist die zuschauer stehen diese mache
ich einfach einen schwimm profi die kids
geht nicht apropos nächsten videos also
es gibt momentan keine videos das heißt
gestern gab es keine chance und das wann
und wo die und genau und sonntag kommen
die videos jetzt trotzdem noch und
sonntags aber nur videos aus den daten
also bitte über schrecken dass kein
kuchen keine rezepte com
es kommt mir das studio selbst durch den
ring am sonntag machen wir ein cooles
hochbeete nachdem schon viele gefragt
wie baue ich ein hochbeet wie die
pflanzlichen hochbeet kommt sondern
riesig müssen ja und ich meine er hat
bestimmt man sich alle meine videos
gesehen das heißt schaut gerne auch mal
ins archiv mehr als letztes jahr genannt
habe ich habe ich alles um rezepte als
rezepte vor allem objekt orten oder auch
gesunde rezepte nach findet ihr auf
jeden fall lassen können auch weiterhin
drin spürt man wir sind etwas denkt
daten wir sind da aber wie gesagt kam
das team hat auch ein recht auf urlaub
und wir wollen uns einfach jetzt erst
mal aufsuchen und so trennt die apple
produkte und alles was wir gerade so
parallel über ein so sommer zieht und
dann haben und pizza waltz ja die haben
ferien die ist auch dass hinweg passen
auch weg und die kids die machen nicht
aber es macht spaß gutes noch gesagt
kapriziert irgendwie geschrieben was ist
dann stimmt nicht
ich glaube ich alles echt ganz ehrlich
ist schön stressig schon ja ich kümmere
mich um daraus halt und die kinder und
es war alles noch was macht schule.de
minuten haben wir dürfen nur 10 44
minuten als clown doch ganze geschichte
erzählt sowas nur noch erzählen wir
machen sobald der frankfurter straße nur
einer von beiden die die kamera halten
machen wir unsere frage antwort video
genau wenn irgendwelche fragen gehen auf
instagram gesammelt auf facebook glaube
ich habe ich auch schon gesammelt weiter
also fragen haben habe gern einen
question and genau zu mercedes auf
deutsch fragen und findet alles fragen
so nette gäste keine dummen fragen
außerhalb und 19 gearbeitet wenn dann
merkt auch dass doktor fragen gibt ja
ansonsten ja es tut gut daran konnte
auch machte wurde im kleinen was wissen
nicht sagst du uns wirklich extrem leid
die zu hause so ich dem rat das ist ja
es ist unsere berlin noch viele viele
andere projekte ist noch geheim
ja zum beispiel die fischer und gemüse
zucht also manchmal video drüber
wir machen jetzt schluss wir sehen uns
ich meine es sind aber auch warnt ja ich
versuche gar die welt zu verändern
wo ich mein neuen erfrischenden diese zu
gemüse züchtig gerade einen teich für
scharfe reiniger 1 mich jetzt noch prinz
harry treffen da will auch mal die welt
verändern ja machen sie auch schauen was
auf jeden fall danke für alles japan
kanada und innehalten
schon wieder stadt haben baden
württemberg ist eben gerade urlaub 1000
richtigen zeit übernommen
genießt das genießt den kids manchmal so
lockt jetzt lasst sie nicht vor dem
handy versandt oder auf dem fernseher
sondern geht mir geht's raus und kunst
auch und draußen binden hauptsache
draußen im einzel der fähre jederzeit
schnell und genau deswegen institut
berlin sein kanal der heißen nicht gern
und unterstrich jenny ja und er ist
übrigens auch mit der heuer beliefern
wir gehen das ist richtig und ich bin
ich dann um laufen und überall teilweise
mit meinhof nur eingehen wenn dieses
video sieht wir werden euch vorbei kommt
lasst euch überraschen gekommen
[Musik]
aber nun laufen nicht abhängen
frische luft einmal um thorsten das
reicht dann für stunden gereicht